بنزيما ترند اول حول العالم والسبب الرحيل
والوجهه القادمه وخبراء بيحذروا جروبس
الواتساب خطر على الصحه النفسيه
وسفير لبناني متهم بالاغتصاب والخارجيه
تفتح تحقيقا احلا بكم
[موسيقى]
كريم بنزيما لاعب كره قدم فرنسي وثاني
هدافي نادي ريال مدريد واليوم راح تكون
مباراه الاخيره مع النادي من بعد 14 سنه
فنادي ريال مدريد اعلن في بيان رسمي عن
اتفاق بين النادي وبين بنزيما لانهاء
مسيرته اللي وصفها البيان بالرائعه
واستعرض البيان انجازات بنزيما من وقت
انضمامه للنادي في 2009 خلال المواسم ال14
اللي شارك فيها واللي فاز خلالها النادي ب
25 لقب وعدد من الجوائز من بينها جائزه
الكره الذهبيه وهو خامس اكثر لاعب مشاركه
بالمباريات في النادي مع
647 مباراه وثاني هداف تاريخي بريال مدريد
بعد رونالدو برصيد اهداف
353 هدف وتابع البيان انه بنزيما اليوم
بيمتلك حق تقرير مستقبله وانه ريال مدريد
منزله وتمنوا التوفيق في المرحله الجديده
من حياته كمان انه الثلاثاء رح يكون في
حفل وداع بحضور رئيس النادي ومن وقت ما
طلع هذا البيان واسم بنزيما طبعا ترند رقم
اول حول حول العالم وفي السعوديه ايضا
تحديدا والسبب هي الاخبار اللي بتتداولها
وسائل اعلام من ايام واللي الان صارت
بتقول انها اقرب للحقيقه مع نهايه مسيره
بنزيما مع الريال بنتكلم عن اخبار
انضمامهم الى نادي الاتحاد لعقد يمتد
لموسمين وزي ما ذكرت مشاهدينا بنزيما كمان
اسمه ترند حول العالم طبعا يعني قصه
الرحيل عن ريال مدريد والعقل وما الى ذلك
وطبعا هو قتلوه مع النادي صولات وجولات
وطبيعي يكون في كثير حديث عنه خاصه من
مشجعي النادي الاخبار كلها للان متناقله
عن وسائل اعلام ما في عليها اي تاكيد لا
من النادي ولا من بنزيما نفسه نحن هنا
طبعا بنتكلم عن النادي الاتحاد وبنزيما
لكن اللي مؤكد عندنا الان عن مصادر مطلعه
هو انه رئيس الاتحاد ونائبه ووصلوا مدريد
من شويه من اسباب الزياره ما احد اعلن
عنها ولكن وسائل الاعلام بتقول انهم هناك
يعني للتوقيع على صفقه انتقال بنزيما
للنادي وبما اننا بنتكلم عن الكره والدوري
السعودي وانضمام لاعبين كمان عالميين لوفي
لازم نقول انه مو بس بنزيما اللي اسمه
ترند في السعوديه فماسي كمان ومن ايام
اسمه واخباره ترند وبرضو في تقارير انه في
طريقه للتعاقد مع نادي السعودي وتحديدا
الاسم المتداول هو الهلال والترند زاد
اكثر واكثر مع اعلان نادي باريس سان
جيرمان عن انتهاء عقد ميسي بعد موسمين
واتمنى له التوفيق في مسيرته الاحترافيه
مخاطر منصات التواصل والتطبيقات على الصحه
النفسيه موضوع مو جديد ومتكلمين فيه كثير
بس في خبراء نفسيين بداوا يتكلموا عن ضرر
نفسي معين نحن بنتكلم عن دراسه حديثه
بتحذر من مخاطر جروبات الواتساب على الصحه
النفسيه يعني كلنا بنقعد بنمزح وبنعلق على
الجروبات وانه كثرتها وتفراتها وقديش
بتفضي شحن التلفون واو لكن الان يبدو
خطوره الموضوع اكبر من كده من الموضوع له
ابعاد نفسيه فالخبراء النفسيين هدول
بيقولوا ان الجروبات بتزيد التوتر والضغط
وبتهز الحاله النفسيه للناس والاسباء او
الاسباب عديده يعني يعني اولا بتسبب صراع
على الاهتمام خاصه لما يكون في جروب كبير
او مثلا كده جروب شغل اما يا سلام عاد لو
في هذا الجروب في مدير او مسؤول يا سلام
وبتعمل كمان انقسامات بين الافراد وكل ما
كثروا الافراد كل ما كثره الانقسامات طبعا
هذا غير انه النقاشات الافتراضيه اصلا
احتماليه الخ فيها اعلى لانه يعني التواصل
فيها ناقص اموميه في الميه وبحسب الخبراء
انه اللي بيزيد من اسباب القلق والتوتر في
الجروبات انه ما في احد بيستشيرنا في كثير
من الاحيان قبل ما يضيفنا يعني فجاه كده
بتلاقي نفسك في جروب ومتورط ومو عارف تطلع
طبعا الان الموضوع صار اهون بعد ما بطلوا
انه يرسلوا للجميع النوتيفيكيشن في الجروب
زمان كان اللي بيترك الجروب يعني فضيحته
بجلاجل يعني الكل جالس بيشوف يعني احنا
شخصين في تفاعلكم لما يعني جرينا الدراسه
حسينا بكثير من الواقعيه فيها وحسينا انه
بتنطبق علينا وحبينا نعرف ارائكم لو انتم
بتتفقوا معنا قمنا سالناكم يعني لو
بتشعروا انه جروبات واتساب بتزيد قلقكم
وتوتركم ويبدو انكم مشاهدينا بتشاركونا
المشاعر لانه اكثر من 46 او 64% عفوا
قالوا نعم بتزيد التوتر والقلق
36% قالوا لا ما بتزيد التوتر ولا القلق
طيب معنى من عمان دكتور ليث العبادي
الطبيب النفسي اهلا فيك معانا دكتور ليث
يعني انا من الناس اللي صوتوا انه يعني
ايه بتزيد القلق والتوتر بس ممكن بعض
الناس شفتهم بيعلق وبيقولوا انه يعني
معليش يا جماعه قلق وتوتر من جروبات
واتساب يعني بتبالغوا هل تعتقد ان الموضوع
مبالغه
هو ليس مبالغه زي ما بنحكي انه التعب
النفسي او اي امور نفسيه هي عباره في كثير
عوامل تلعب فيها دور تغيرات والضغوط
الخارجيه وطريقه استجابتي لهاي الضغوطات
فزي ما اي ضغط نفسي في ناس ممكن
تنضعه وكان نفس الشيء في ناس موضوع
التواصل
الاجتماعي ضغط اكثر من الاشخاص الاخرين
بنوعا ما بالتاثير افعالهم على شعور
الارض ممكن يكونوا اقل تاثرا بس اللي
بيهتم
فلان يشعر وكيف فلان بيحبني ونظره الاخرين
له يكون عنده يقظه اعلى بالتدقيق على هل
رديت على انبعتلي رساله هلا اللي بيتعامل
مع الواتساب كمهام يريد ان ينجزها
بشكل عليه الضغط اعلى من تقصد انه مو بس
كمان داخل الجروبات لا لمن يشوف علامه
الجروبات انه فيها مسجات هذا الشيء بسبب
له توتر قلق انه لمن يشوفه يعني
كل انواع او التنبيهات على
من وسائل اللي فيها رساله الرساله هي كانه
بقول لك يا ساره يا ساره كيف حالك صباح
الخير فانت اختلطت العالم بتطور وطريقه
التواصل قاعده بتزيد كانت زمان تليفونات
ارضي بعدين صار اتصال هاتفي
اتصالات وهسه على الواتساب من عده تطبيقات
فانت كميه انا في عملي عنا وسائل تواصل مع
المراجعين
او حتى في كل مكان داخل الواتساب صار جزء
جزء من العمل وجزء من الحياه الشخصيه لا
ما انا يمكن بدي اكلمك كمان على موضوع
العمل هذا بس قبلها يعني بدي اقول لك
واحده من الاشياء كمان اللي جدا يعني
بتزيد القلق لما احد يكتب لك مثلا مثلا
تدخل الجروب يكتب ساره طيب يوم ما يكمل
طيب انا عارفه انه اسمي ساره اكيد في
كارثه بعد صار هذه اللي كاتبها مثلا
قبل ما ترمي القنبله بده يحط اطفال
لما كانت والدتك ووالدك يحكي تعال بدي
اياك في موضوع اللحظه اللي بيناديك للحظه
اللي بخبرك شو القصه
نفسي كل اخطائك بتعدي قدامك وتكون
بتفكر ايوه ايش عملت ايش عملت شو عملت هل
عزمت ما عزمت دعيته هل حكيت عنه لمين حكيت
الحكي هذا يلعبوا بنفسيتك صراحه ايه هم
الامهات سببوا الواتساب في اللعب بالنفسيه
يعني بس خليني اخذك على موضوع اهل
الجروبات العمل تحديدا يعني جروبات العمل
كمان فيها صراعات والسياسه اللي في المكتب
بتتنقل للواتساب ولو في مدير في الجروب
كمان يصير الكل بيحاول انه يعني يعمل انه
رهيب قدام الجروب لاي درجه هذا كمان يعني
بياثر فعليا على خلينا نقول صحه الموظف
وهل يعني فعلا نقدر نحكم على الموظف من
واتساب
اذا تم ضبط
طريقه التواصل ممكن نحد من المدار اذا كان
مفتوح وهو لا يوجد اي يعني ضوابط او
قوانين كيف احنا بنستخدم الواتساب سيكون
له تاثير سلبي على العمل يعني رح يصفي
الكل عم بحكي الرسائل المهمه سوف تضيع حتى
انا مع مراجعيني في عندي رقم واتساب مختص
للعمل بحكي لهم هذا رقم الواتساب ولكن بحط
قواعد للتواصل ما تتوقع ارد في نفس اليوم
انا عندي كل يومين او ثلاث في الصباح بفتح
الرسائل برد عليها بتعامل معها كانها
ايميل لا تتوقع في المساء دكتور كيفك انا
الان متوتر عشان بشرح القواعد اللي انا
وضعتها للموضوع خففت من القلق اللي ممكن
ينتج انه انه اذا حدا بعث لي رساله وما
رديت طب ليش الدكتور مش عم بيرد ليش شو
اللي عم بيصير هل هو
مثلا قرات وما رديته بس يعني هذه خلي
الدكتور يعني اوصل معاك لنقطه انه احنا
اكيد ما حنحذف التطبيق خلاص وصلنا للمرحله
ما نقدر نحذفه يعني انت برايك انه انه نحط
كل واحد يحط قواعد عامه ويرسلها للناس هذه
قواعيدي انا بحكي في العمل طب بس بالناس
في حياتنا الخاصه يعني جروبات الاهالي ترى
بتضغط نفسيا كمان
في قواعد العمل
المطلوب عليه يحط قواعد للمجموعه بحيث انك
الشخصيه انت ضع قواعدك لنفسك انا مثلا ما
بفتح الواتساب بعد العشره بالليل انا اي
شخص بده يبعث لي في ناس بحط
او
المعلومه اللي بحطها في ناس بكتب لا تبعث
لي 30 ثانيه
الحاله اللي هو حاطها
بخسوب قائد الاساسيه تبعته للتواصل وانت
كشخص تقدر انت ترضع قوانين خاصه مناسبه
فيك وانت بتقدر تدرس
نفسيتك اللي قاعد بصير من الواتساب او من
غيره من وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وتحد
نفسك فيها في معلومه بدي احكيها انه علم
النفس بتطور وببحث دائما تجديد صارت
الابحاث والدراسات تروح على التكنولوجيا
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي صارت جزء كبير من
حياتنا في تشخيصات جديده في في الطب
النفسي راح تدخل وراح تنضاف لها علاقه
بالتكنولوجيا واولا اللي هو ادمان الالعاب
الالكترونيه مثلا لا وكمان يعني لهجانب
ايجابي كمان ممكن دكتور يمكن يوم ثاني
نتكلم عنه في التواصل واحيانا فعلا بيروح
عنك وكل هذا الكلام كله بس حاجرب موضوع
اني احط قواعد في الجروب اللي فيه امي
وخالتي واذا يعني كنت سليمه بكره فالامور
ان شاء الله عدت بتمام مجيد بكره الدوام
يعني اعرف انه انتهى وضعيه على العموم
هنجرب الاسلوب ده بشكرك جدا على هذه
المداخله كان معنى من عمان دكتور ليث
العبادي الطبيب النفسي شكرا لك
الم من جديد للاسف الشديد يعني قصص واخبار
الجرائم والاغتصاب ما بتغيب عن الاخبار
واليوم عندنا موضوع من هذا النوع والمتهم
مسؤول دبلوماسي رفيع فالسفير اللبناني في
فرنسا رامي عدوان يواجه اتهامات في شبهه
اغتصاب وعنف متعمد قدمت هذا الضم موظفتين
سابقتين في السفاره في باريس في البدايه
من مقال نشروا موقع ميديا عن معلومات
لملاحقات قضائيه بحق السفير من بعد ما
تقدمت سيدتين بشكاوى اغتصاب وعنف ضده وانه
القضاء الفرنسي مو قادر يحاكموا بسبب
الحصانه اول شكوى من موظفه سابقه بالسفاره
اسمها ابا وعمرها 31 تقدمت بشكوى في يونيو
22 وقالت فيها انه
انها تعرضت للاغتصاب في مايو بشقه خاصه
تابعه للسفير عدوان وقالت انها كانت على
علاقه معه وكان بيعنفها جسديا ونفسيا كل
يوم وقالت انها كانت تعرضت لعدوان بمكتبه
في 2020 وما اشتكت عليه
عشان ما تدمر حياتهم تتعرضت تحيد تحديدا
من قبل لاعتداء في عشرين عشرين ولكن ما
بلغت عنه كونوا متزوج وعنده اسره اما
السيده الثانيه فعمرها 28 سنه واسمها
جبريل وتقدمت بشكوى ضده في فبراير وقالت
انه قيم بالاعتداء الجسدي عليها من بعد
رفضها انها تدخل معاه في علاقه جنسيه
واتهمته بانه حاول يدهسها بسيارته بعد
خلاف بيناتهم على هامش منتدى من اجل
السلام في سبتمبر وانه كمان حاول يخنقها
في ديسمبر ومسك بيدها ورقبتها وحشر وجهها
في السرير وانه تركها وكانت على حافه
الموت
ومن بعد تداول الاخبار هذه اعلنت وزاره
الخارجيه اللبنانيه ببيان انها حريصه على
التعاطي بمسؤوليه مع القضيه بما يصون سمعه
ومكانه الدوله وانه تقرر استعجال ايفاد
لجنه تحقيق برئاسه الامين العام للوزاره
وعضويه مدير التفتيش الى السفاره في باريس
للتحقيق مع السفير المعني والاستماع
لافادات موظفيه السفاره من دبلوماسيين
واداريين وتابع البيان بانه راح تقابل
اللجنه من يلزم من الجهات الرسميه
الفرنسيه لايضاح التي تم تداوله بالاعلام
ولم تتبلغوا الخارجيه اللبنانيه عبر
القنوات الدبلوماسيه اصولا اما الخارجيه
الفرنسيه فنقلت وكاله فرانس عنها مطالبتها
برفع السلطات اللبنانيه الحصانه عن السفير
رامي عدوان لتسهيل عمل القضاء الفرنسي
بالقضيه وبالنسبه للسفير فقال محامي كريم
بلوني انه موكله في كل الاتهامات الموجهه
ضد سواء كانت لفظيه او اخلاقيه او جنسيه
او انه السفير كان على علاقه مع السيدتين
بين عامي 2018
و2022 وتخللت علاقته معهما خلافات وحالات
انفصال وقال في تصريحات خاصه نقلتها عنه
جريده النهار اللبنانيه انه للان ما تبلغ
باي شكوى ضده ولا اثرت الاخبار على مسار
عمله الدبلوماسي
في فيديو متداول على المنصات سعوديين بشكل
كبير اليومين الماضيين والفيديو بيظهر
تاثره فرح اب بتخرج ابنته انت بوجهي لا
تخافي من دنيات عن كل الماضي يخوفك لا
تخافي
لو الليالي والزمان يتحدات
لا يضيق خاطر عسى ما تضيقه
كل الظروف اللي تشوفين
نامي على راحتي لا تبالي
يبين خافيت ولا يطلع اقساط وانا بعيشه
بعمري
الفيديو اتضح انه من تخريج جامعه الملك
خالد في ابها وكان الخميس الماضي وحصد
الكثير بالكثير من المشاهدات من الناس
اللي تاثرت بتاثر الوالد لكن التاثر تضاعف
بشكل اكبر بكثير لما اتضحت القصه الحقيقيه
الخريجه واسمها سميره هي ابنه الرجل في
الفيديو بالتبني فهو كان بيشتغل في مستشفى
ولاحظ انه تسعه اشهر والطفله موجوده فتعلق
فيها فاخذها رغم انه عنده ثمانيه ابناء
وبنات ومنهم من اللي هم في سنها اصلا
ورضعت في منزله وصارت من ابنائه واخبرته
وصلوا لسميره ووالدها وحكوا قصته
[موسيقى]
سميره ولدت عام 2001 واخذناه وعمرها
تقريبا تسع شهور كانت عز السرير تهز
السرير تهز السرير تنام
احتملت اني صرت اخذها من فتره فتره طلعها
بره وادور باكلها اذا تعلقت وتعلقت بي ثم
اراد الله سبحانه وتعالى ان تاتينا
[موسيقى]
طبعا
رضعناها وكان اصغر اولادي في سنها سبب
بكاي انا والله ما العب
على هذا شفت ثمره تعبنا وجهدنا يمشي
امامنا في الميدان
الحمد لله الذي رزقني هذه العائله عشت
معاهم 21 سنه وتزوجت والان عمري 22 سنه
عمرهم ما قالوا لي لا عمرهم ما فرقوا بيني
وبين اخواني اخواتي
[موسيقى]
هو واحد من مختصي الذكاء الاصطناعي
المشهورين في العالم والاشهر الماضيه
قداها او قضاها بحذر النواب والناس من
المخاطر المرتبطه فيه مثله مثل كثار من
المختصين في المجال ومن كم يوم كان حديث
وجدت فيها التحذيرات والمخاوف
وا يعني
جاري مثل ما سمعتوه ذكر بمخاطره وحذر لكن
جاري مو من اللي وقعوا على البيان الجماعي
اللي تكلمنا عنه من كم يوم واللي حذر من
خطر انقراض البشريه اللي ممكن يتسبب في
الذكاء الاصطناعي جاري ماركوس ورغم كل
تحذيراته من الذكاء الاصطناعي لكن لما
ننسال عن الانقراض قال هذه مخاوف مبالغ
فيها
يعني
وبما اننا بنتكلم عن الذكاء الاصطناعي ففي
فيديو منتشر على المنصات حول العالم وعامل
قلق وبلبله مع انه طوله ما بيتجاوز كم
ثانيه
[موسيقى]
مثل ما شفتم في الفيديو رابط باستفعليا
قربوا من شكل وحركات البشر مو عادي لون
الجلد الشعر الرمشه كله مو معقول قد ايش
شكله حقيقي والناس بدات تتداول الفيديو
وتعلق على حقيقه شكله او قديش حقيقي شكله
وقديش هذا الموضوع بشكل عام مرعب وتخيلوا
عاد علشان يزيدوا الرعب بيكون من بين
المعلقين الان ماسك اللي شاف الفيديو
واكتفى بالتعليق بعلامه تعجب الحقيقي
الواحد على فيديو زياده محتاج علامات تعجب
كثيره مو وحده بس يعني صراحه على فكره هذا
مو الفيديو الوحيد فمن كم يوم في بريطانيا
كان في معرض روبوتات
روبوتات ههه والحاضرين انصدموا من روابط
محاكي للبشر فعليا يخوف هذا
الرابط اللي شفتوه الان اسمه اميكا وهو
معروف انه من اكثر الروبوتات العالم تقدما
وتطورا وهم بيكلموه في المعرض سالوه عن
الذكاء الاصطناعي وحذرهم منه
مشاهدين احنا وصلنا لخدام حلقه اليوم انا
اعود والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله في حلقه
جديده من تفاعلكم في امان الله
[موسيقى]